Veamos si podemos dibujar la estructura de Lewis
para un anión nitrato. Un anión nitrato tiene 1
nitrógeno, 3 oxígenos, y tiene una carga negativa.
Pausa el video y trata de dibujar la estructura de
Lewis para un anión nitrato. Muy bien. Bueno,
lo hemos hecho muchas veces. El primer paso es
simplemente contar los electrones de valencia.
El nitrógeno tiene 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 electrones
de valencia en su capa externa, en la segunda
capa; si es 1 átomo de nitrógeno neutro libre,
de modo que tenemos 5 electrones de valencia allí.
El oxígeno tiene 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 electrones de
valencia, pero si tienes 3 oxígenos vas a tener 6
x 3, y si sólo sumaras los electrones de valencia,
si éstos fueran átomos neutros libres, obtendría 5
+ 18 que son 23 electrones de valencia. Ahora, lo
siguiente que debemos tener en mente es que esto
es un anión, esto tiene una carga negativa de 1,
entonces tendrá un electrón extra, un electrón
de valencia más de lo que esperaríamos si
éstos fueran sólo átomos neutros libres, así que
agreguemos un electrón de valencia aquí, esto nos
da 24 electrones de valencia. El siguiente paso
es intentar dibujar esta estructura. La forma de
hacerlo es elegir el átomo menos electronegativo
que no sea el hidrógeno para hacer el átomo
central. En este caso es el nitrógeno, está a
la izquierda del oxígeno en el segundo periodo,
así que pongamos el nitrógeno en el centro, justo
aquí, y a su alrededor pongamos 3 oxígenos: 1, 2,
3 oxígenos; pongamos un enlace simple entre
ellos. Hasta ahora hemos considerado 2, 4,
6 electrones de valencia, así que -6 electrones de
valencia, nos quedan 18 electrones de valencia. En
el siguiente paso intentaremos asignar tantos
de éstos como sea posible a nuestros átomos
terminales, a los oxígenos que tenemos aquí,
intentaremos llevarlos a un octeto completo,
hagamos eso. Cada uno de estos oxígenos ya está
participando en uno de estos enlaces covalentes,
entonces ya tienen 2 electrones de valencia,
así que veamos si podemos darle 6 a cada uno
para llegar a los 8: 2, 4, 6; 2, 4, 6 y luego 2, 4
y 6, así hemos asignado 18 electrones de valencia:
6, 12, 18, entonces -18 electrones de valencia.
Ahora nos quedamos sin electrones de valencia
para asignar, pero veamos cómo están nuestros
átomos. Sabemos que los oxígenos tienen su octeto
completo, pero el nitrógeno sólo tiene 2, 4, 6
electrones de valencia. Sería genial si hubiera
una estructura de Lewis donde pudiéramos tener 8
electrones de valencia para ese nitrógeno. Bueno,
una forma de hacer eso es tomar uno de estos
pares solitarios de uno de los oxígenos y
convertirlo en otro enlace covalente, hagamos
eso. Déjame borrar este par justo aquí y voy a
convertirlo en otro enlace covalente. Esto se ve
bastante bien. Tenemos 8 electrones de valencia
alrededor de cada uno de los oxígenos.
Ahora tenemos 8 para el nitrógeno: 2,
4, 6, 8. Y tenemos que recordar que esto es un
anión, tiene una carga negativa. Para terminar
la estructura de Lewis simplemente ponemos esa
carga negativa aquí. Y todo esto está muy bien,
pero si esta fuera la única forma en que existiera
el nitrato, al observar aniones de nitrato en la
naturaleza esperaríamos ver 1 enlace más corto
y 2 enlaces más largos, y esperaríamos que uno
de los enlaces tuviera una energía diferente que
los otros dos. Pero en el mundo real no vemos eso,
vemos que todos los enlaces en realidad tienen
la misma longitud y en realidad tienen la misma
energía. Así que una pregunta interesante
es ¿por qué pasa eso? Una cosa que podrías
apreciar es que cuando tomé este par solitario
para crear este enlace covalente podría haberlo
hecho con ese oxígeno superior, podría haberlo
hecho con este oxígeno inferior izquierdo o
podría haberlo hecho con ese oxígeno inferior
derecho. Hay tres estructuras de Lewis válidas,
no sólo podríamos haber tenido esta estructura
de Lewis, podríamos haber tenido esta. Lo
dibujaré todo en amarillo para ahorrarnos algo
de tiempo. Donde tienes este nitrógeno que tiene
un enlace simple con ese oxígeno superior, así
el oxígeno superior todavía tiene 6 electrones
en pares solitarios; tal vez forma un doble
enlace con el oxígeno inferior izquierdo.
Así que este oxígeno inferior izquierdo sólo
tiene 2 pares solitarios, uno de ellos habría
ido a formar el doble enlace, y este oxígeno
se vería igual. Lo que estoy dibujando aquí,
es otra estructura de Lewis válida. O el doble
enlace podría haberse formado con este oxígeno
inferior derecho, así que déjenme dibujar eso.
Otra estructura de Lewis válida podría verse así:
el nitrógeno unido a ese oxígeno tiene 3 pares
solitarios, este oxígeno también tiene 3 pares
solitarios y ahora este tiene el doble enlace y
sólo tiene 2 pares solitarios. Cada vez que vemos
una situación donde tenemos 3 estructuras
de Lewis válidas lo llamamos resonancia,
resonancia. Pondremos flechas bidireccionales
entre estas estructuras, y cuando escuchas la
palabra "resonancia" a veces evocas esta imagen
de que estás rebotando, que estás resonando entre
estas estructuras, pero eso en realidad no es
correcto. La forma correcta de pensar en esto
es que estas diferentes formas de visualizar el
nitrato contribuyen a un híbrido de resonancia,
que es realmente la verdadera forma en la que el
nitrato existe. Así que si quisiéramos dibujar
un híbrido de resonancia se vería así: tienes el
nitrógeno en el centro, tienes tus oxígenos 1, 2,
3, puedo dibujar nuestro primer enlace covalente
así y luego mostrarías que el enlace entre el
nitrógeno y cada uno de estos oxígenos son un
híbrido entre un enlace simple y un enlace doble,
y así, en lugar de que sólo uno de ellos tenga
el doble enlace y los otros dos tengan enlaces
simples, todos están en algún punto intermedio.
Tal vez dibujes una línea punteada, algo así, para
mostrar cuál es la realidad. En realidad tienes 3
enlaces que están en algún lugar, entre un enlace
simple y un doble enlace, porque los electrones
en esta molécula se deslocalizan por completo. Y,
por supuesto, siempre quieres asegurarte de
que la gente reconozca que esto es un anión.
De modo que esta es la idea de resonancia:
tienes múltiples estructuras de Lewis válidas,
todas contribuyen a un híbrido de resonancia que
en realidad es lo que observamos, no sólo estamos
rebotando entre estas estructuras, la observación
real sería un híbrido de los tres. Ahora, lo que
acabamos de dibujar aquí es que estos tres son
equivalentes, pero en ciertos casos veremos esto.
En los videos siguientes no tenemos estructuras
equivalentes y algunas de ellas podrían contribuir
más al híbrido de resonancia que otras,
pero eso lo veremos en videos siguientes.